Here I am right now standing before you
free to talk i should be ten months into
a 10-year prison sentence the only
reason why I'm standing here because I
happen to know about jury nullification
and I used it hi I'm Zack Weiss Muller
with reason TV I'm here with Eadie
fortune also known as the New Jersey
weed man or the NJ weed man
he's a former marijuana dispensary owner
a medical marijuana patient and an
outspoken advocate for jury
nullification who's successfully fought
back multiple marijuana charges Edie
thank you very much for joining us no
problem
jury nullification is what we call the
outcome when essentially a defendant has
violated a law but the jury believes
that the law itself is unjust or not
properly applied in that situation how
does jury nullification play into your
personal story and the cases that you
fought I was charged in New Jersey with
with possession of marijuana and
possession with intent to distribute but
I have always felt that the marijuana
laws were wrong opinion poll left
opinion poll shows that more than 50% of
Americans believe that marijuana should
be legal taking those numbers and
putting it on a jury I believe that uh
you know anyone charged with violating a
marijuana events should be able to argue
to his jury that the law is wrong and
should be able about half the jury to
say not guilty so you had medical
marijuana that you'd obtained in
California and brought to New Jersey
then what happened a police officer
pulled you over a New Jersey State
Trooper pulled up next to me at a light
and you know I don't know if it's
because I got nervous or whatever but he
was paying attention to me
I had my front tires over the white line
and that was the pretext stop that he
used to stop me say that I disregarded a
traffic signal because my front tires
were over a white line anyway he pulled
me over he asked he asked for a certain
if he can search and said no it didn't
matter he put me in a car he got a judge
a couple hours later to sign a search
warrant and he searched a car and they
found my suitcase with my luggage my
toothpaste and my medicine they
seemingly had all the evidence they
would need to convict you under the law
how did you win that case well basically
I was guilty you know I got caught
red-handed too but the fact that matter
still goes back to most Americans
believe marijuana's laws are wrong and
that was what I argued first of all I
represented myself I think I think
people who who were charged with a
violent man wanna offense should
represent themselves and alameen totally
by themselves but at least give their
opening statements so you're identifying
with the juror the jurors can identify
with you and that's why I did I gave in
my opening statement I basically
introduced myself you know I removed
myself from being a criminal and turned
myself into the victim of a wrong law
and I explained how I smoked the joint
this morning I'm gonna smoke a joint at
lunchtime and we should explain that you
do have a very serious medical condition
that you say that marijuana alleviates
right yes I have bone cancer I got I got
diagnosed thirteen years ago I've had a
couple operations where I've had tumors
removed the last three years I've been
suffering with one a huge tumor in my
right femur which is basically just
painful as pain levels and I could get
on percocets and hide record gnomes and
all kinds of pain medicines but I have
chosen not to I don't want to be
addicted to those dangerous substances
instead I use natural marijuana for my
pain how much of your argument were you
actually able to make that you know what
this law is wrong I'm I'm the victim in
this case I imagine that would be a
challenge to even be allowed to say that
in a courtroom so how much of that were
you able to get in all of it really yes
and it was my mission it was a whole
plan of mine I basically I've been
calling myself a New Jersey weed man for
the last 15 years because I was
advocating the legalization of marijuana
but I always had this plan the plan was
jury nullification I could have just
easily called myself jury nullification
man so to me when when I went on trial
was like my Super Bowl like it was like
I
planning for this for a long time and
basically the judge and the prosecutor
and all the pretrial lead-ups tried to
stop me from saying certain things I
went around them even just representing
myself you know I'm giving my opening
statement the prosecutor gets to say
what he thinks the case is about I have
to say what I thought they think that's
an it that might be an advantage of
representing yourself because other
because defense attorneys are probably
afraid of being disbarred and other kind
of punishments right I think it's a must
you know I've been telling a lot of
people over the internet how I did it
how to do it and I think that's like
number one you should you should
represent yourself if you don't totally
represent yourself you should at least
give your own opening statement
because like I said you're you're
removing yourself as the criminal in the
matter and you turn yourself in the into
the victim the number two thing is jury
selection some people would argue to
jury selection is number one but juries
aren't like superhuman super American
super patriots what they are their
everyday average Americans they they
have brothers sisters cousins of smoked
marijuana or my jury I suspect at least
two of them smoked marijuana I was
looking for pot heads on my jury I
looked the stereotypical pothead you
know I'm not to be honest which I'm very
highly motivated I you know I get things
done as long as the government doesn't
bother there's a lot of pressure like
you mentioned from the prosecutors from
the judge who's going to be saying
things like you need to follow the law
as the laws explain to you I have sat in
drug court rooms where they say it's not
about the morality of the law it's not
about if you like this person or not
those are huge hurdles to overcome when
a figure of authority is saying that to
a jury huh what do you think was the
most important thing and kind of
breaking past all that I think by
representing myself and speaking for
myself I put myself into a different
category there's a lot of anti lawyer
animosity in the war in America too so I
capitalized on that you know I described
my my prosecutor and not good terms and
I felt like the the the prosecutor and a
judge and even a public defender we're
all on the same team where I described
myself as a
being all we to people's team and you
the tourists that's the team I want and
I actually begged them to save my life I
predicted that there was at least 50% of
my jurors are going to believe that
marijuana should be legal I said that I
would probably get five or six on my
sides it turned out I got seven
prosecutors he decided to retry me again
and the second trial he only surprised
that I had was I got 12 this time a kind
of broader critique that you hear of
jury nullification is that you know laws
come about through a process and this is
kind of subverting that process it's
undermining the rule of law to just have
these rogue juries deciding what's right
and wrong in some situations it could
target minorities because an all-white
jury might nullify a crime against a
minority plaintiff so how do you respond
to that kind of critique of
nullification jury nullification
absolutely does hat is a double-edged
sword I mean it cuts both ways generally
I look at during nullification as a
barometer of public acceptance there are
laws that we can look at and say that
are wrong or were wrong and the public
starts accepting that prior to the
legislators the slavery acts of the
1850s you know the public wasn't down
with slavery anymore so they weren't
going to help people getting prosecuted
for for helping slaves escape during the
alcohol prohibition here in America same
thing happened that's what I think we're
at that stage in history now with
marijuana even if the person doesn't
smoke marijuana they're on the internet
they're reading the truth they don't
believe the lies the government said you
know the government is has turned into
the the emperor with no clothes if
anyone runs into trouble and finds
themselves in a position where they need
to defend themselves and they want to
pursue the strategies you've been
talking about what's your advice where
can they look for resources what's the
first what are the first steps the fully
informed jury Association fi J a org is
an organization it puts out a lot of
information I got a lot of information
from them
I have information on my website NJ weed
mancom represent yourself speak to the
jury yourself actively and aggressively
challenge the law say the law is wrong
Here I am right now standing before you
free to talk
I should be 10 months into a 10-year
prison sentence the only reason why I'm
standing here is because I happen to
know about jury nullification and I used
it I'm glad for that and thank you very
much at fortune to new jersey weed man
thanks for talking with us for reason TV
I'm Zack Weiss Muller